and i'm sorry that you haven't seen me
in a while and i'm hoping
that this video clears up a lot of the
reasons why
i felt i could not be online over the
past couple of months
just when you thought 2020 couldn't get
any more dramatic
the youtube beauty community drama just
went nuclear oh my god
you are so manipulative tati westbrook
dropped a bombshell
a 40-minute long video on tuesday in
which she claims
shane dawson and jeffrey starr
weaponized her
to bring down fellow beauty blogger
james
charles i can tell you this it's now my
opinion that jeffrey and shane were both
bitterly jealous of james charles's
success
jeffrey resented that so much of his
business was centered around his biggest
rival
and shane did not like that james
charles wanted to make a documentary
neither of them were happy with standing
in his shadow on youtube anymore
shane responded almost immediately
reacting live on instagram as she
accused him
and jeffrey of manipulating her into
making
last year's video where she publicly cut
ties with the mega beauty blogger
oh my god you are so manipulative you're
a fake crying you are fake
crying you are fake crying that is not
real
oh my god backstory tati called out her
then bff james charles last spring
for not supporting her vitamin brand
during coachella
and stagecoach and called the 21 year
old
makeup gurus sexual endeavors into
question
within the videos i did not make my
video because of vitamins
i made it as a result of all of the
poisonous lies that were fed to me
by shane dawson and jeffrey starr in
tati's
latest video called breaking my silence
the beauty vlogger apologizes for her
actions to a few people
including james who has yet to respond
james i am so sorry that i allowed
myself to be poisoned
and weaponized against you i'm sorry
that i bought into any of their lies
believing those lies and allowing myself
to be gaslit into making that video is
one of the biggest regrets of my life
the information they were giving me was
terrifying
i thought your career and freedom were
in jeopardy
i was trying to get you to put your
phone down and seek help because
i was told there were a lot of victims
that were going to come forward to
destroy you
i was foolish for believing them i was
scared i thought if i called you out
you would put your phone down and stop
the detrimental behavior
i was being made to believe was true
james i apologize for uploading that
video the bombshell video comes
just days after shane's apology video
taking accountability dropped
in which the youtuber apologizes for a
long
list of past offenses including saying
the n-word his pedophilia jokes
and the biggest problem with me doing
that
and posting it on the internet was it
made
young people at the time who were
watching me think it was okay
and and that's the craziest part it's
like i've had people
tell me well i used to watch your videos
when i was a kid and yeah i never saw
anything wrong with that
and that is scary because it made me
realize oh my god
i have been a part of such a huge
problem and
i have just been avoiding it and that's
wrong
so i'm so sorry then jada pinkett smith
got involved
and wasn't having any of it calling out
the 31 year old vlogger
shortly after the video went live with
this tweet
to shane dawson i'm done with the
excuses
after yet another old video of him
resurfaced
where shane was making sexual gestures
at a poster
of a then 11 year old willow smith
willow's brother jayden
doubled down on shane calling him
disgusting
although shane has yet to respond to the
smiths
there's no amount of apologizing that
can take it away
and take away the impact it had and take
away the amount of people
that have been hurt by that or have felt
like i
i was just another white guy who can get
away with everything
now it seems because of shane's
checkered online past
youtube may have suspended monetization
on three of his channels this according
to buzzfeed news
that includes shane's main channel shane
which has 22 million subscribers
and his beauty channel that boasts 3.7
million
i'm ready to to own up to this stuff and
i'm ready to
hopefully show you guys that it's okay
to admit when you're wrong
it's okay to be upset at your past self
for making mistakes but also it's okay
if people don't want to accept your
apology or if people
don't want to support you anymore that's
okay too